all right people
i believe we are live minor technical
difficulties here
in the brand spanking new studio we're
in google live streaming
and across from me across the pond i've
got
carl benjamin aka sargon of akkad carl
how are you
very glad to uh finally have it all
working how are you doing
i'm good i have to say you're a very
patient person because
when the stream went down you're very
calm are you are you on the drugs
uh no i'm just used to google hangouts
once once we get the studio fully going
we have some like fancy tricaster stuff
that'll we won't have to do it through
hangouts so we're
we're doing the best we can in this
crazy time how do you like our sort of
uh well this is the new set and we we
faked it a little to look like there's
just some stuff going on how does that
look to you um it looks uh in progress
in progress exactly all right all right
there's a ton i want to talk to you
about
and uh you know when we did this i had
you on my show i think
a little over a year ago now uh i said
to you that when i was sort of having my
kind of awakening about what was going
on with the left and that i felt that
liberals
were no longer liberal they were
becoming illiberal and
progressives were becoming regressives
when i started tweeting about this stuff
and sort of
awakening to it everybody online on
twitter and on facebook was saying
sargon of akkad is the guy you have to
talk to this is what he's been talking
about
and all that stuff so for the people
that don't know who you are
um first just tell me a little bit about
yourself privately and then sort of
when you woke up to what you now see as
uh as a big problem on the left there
are people who don't know who i am
i'd like to meet them for the three or
four people who just got the internet
this week you know
i only say that but i've actually had
people in real life say my friend's a
really big fan of yours and i was
thinking oh my god
you know that's that's worrying isn't it
like
but um yeah it's like you just sit in a
little room and you talk and then holy
cow people are watching
i know um yeah i guess um it was about
three years ago now that well i mean it
must have been before that but i just
in the news i just kept seeing things
that were just
objectionable and normally these
objectionable things would be coming
from
the right uh but this was coming from
the left and it was
coming from people who i thought should
know better and from people who had a
great deal of influence and
and once at mainstream media like
newspapers and television outlets and
stuff like this and i'm
thinking why are they effectively
why are they doing all this why are they
going so far outside of the bounds of
what you would think
is an appropriate position you know i
mean so give me an example of something
that you saw that you were like wait a
minute wait a minute
what's happening here oh god this is
years ago now i can't
i can't even remember i can barely
remember what i saw last week
all right well okay so without giving
what you know specifics
yeah sorry forget forgetting the
specifics then give me your liberal
cred because one of the things that i
see pop up sometimes is that for those
of us that are on the left
that that criticize the left and as i
say all the time there's a zillion of us
that criticize the right
i criticize the right too but yes i
focus on the left because i want my team
to be better
can you give me some of your liberal
credentials so that people will say
people will go oh he actually is a
liberal or a classical liberal
what do you even consider yourself i
really i do consider myself to be a
classical liberal
um i am very concerned that
all people be treated the same within
the under the in the eyes of the law
that that's one thing that really
concerns me um i mean
liberalism springs from individual
rights and the very idea of group rights
is it's just
the complete opposite of what they're
trying to achieve in fact that was the
thing that
liberalism was really trying to defeat
the whole
if you have a system of universal rights
and then you give a certain group a
certain number of rights
that the other people don't have a not
only is that obviously by default not
universal
but b it creates a group of people
who have different rules to the rest of
you how is that any different to an
aristocracy
that's my you know i just i just can't
get over that that is the the
fundamental point
of why i dislike group rights and any
liberal should be against group rights
whereas progressives seem remarkably in
favor of group rights and
i'm just in awe that they don't seem to
understand that that's an
anti-liberal position to hold you know
when they say okay we want this for
black people who want this for women you
know quotas or
anything of the sort it's like no you
know we we're all
equals we're all going to be treated as
equals under the law and we're going to
have
that we're not no special favors because
under what in what world does being
black or a woman
or any other kind of minority category
inform you really about that
person you can't ever say well yeah well
he's black
therefore and they're a woman therefore
you know you can never tell anything
about anyone's kind of personality or
anything like that
or the character or their achievements
or their you know anything
and so it just really drives me crazy
when i i i guess it was
i mean looking back i guess it was the
increasing encroachment of identity
politics
into the left and not even encroachment
just the sort of steamrolling of the
left
from identity politics it's been
infuriating because it
it's inherently chauvinistic it drives
me crazy it's like okay so
i mean if we take it like an example
like um violence against women you think
oh my god
domestic violence against women that's
awful and then you look at the
statistics
40 of domestic violence is against men
so if you're gonna say right okay we're
concerned with violence against women
you are
implicitly saying you're not caring
about violence against men
and it's not even the fact that violence
is going on that's really the problem
it's the fact that women are suffering
as a group rather than
individuals whoever's suffering from
violence because everyone suffers from
violence you know when
when someone has something done to them
they suffer you know there's
i don't think we should really even be
considering who suffers more
you know we've got systems in place that
say right okay you don't abuse each
other
if someone's been the recipient of abuse
why does it matter
what their characteristics are so
right so basically as as a classical
liberal you believe in
individual liberty you believe in uh
the individual versus the collective you
want everyone to be treated equally now
i
try my best and i probably fail at this
all the time
but i try not to impugn the motivations
of the progressives now obviously i
think the progressives have lost their
mind
hence they've gone from progressive to
regressive um
but do you believe that they knowingly
are doing something bad like
it's hard to say and i know that goes
from you know you've got the leaders of
the movement first the average
you know a lot of these ideas sound good
to kids which is why socialism
suddenly sounds good to kids even though
we know it's never
done any good anywhere but what do you
think about the motivations of these
people because a lot of them you know
they say well
we want uh minorities to be treated
equal so we should have quotas now i get
why
that doesn't really work in reality of
course but but that concept
well one of okay just a uh we want
minorities to be treated
equally then quotas i mean that's not an
equal treatment unless you're going to
have a quota of white people they
they have this in the british
broadcasting corporation in britain
right
where they they will literally advertise
jobs and say
uh this is open to non-whites um they
call them
black asian or minority ethnic
in britain uh but basically they just
mean non-white and
and it's not i mean if it was for say
like um
a television program or something that
was a period piece or something like
that say in
africa or something i would say of
course you're not gonna have like you
know
white people in pre-colonial africa but
when it's for like a research position
like an 18 grand a year research
position
why on earth can you justify saying well
you know what we just don't want white
people for that
and it's just crazy so that's you can't
do that um what was the first part of
the question again sorry
well that do you think they all sort of
know this like oh right
like we know that it's bad we know that
it's obviously bad and that's why i'm
always
for the individual i would be for what
martin luther king said don't judge
someone
by the color of their skin but by the
content of their character but do you
think that all of the people that we're
railing against all the time
do you think they fully get it no no
this it is a lot like socialism as you
say it
a lot of it sounds good on paper and
this
draws a lot of people in because it's
always pitched as a moral
attitude this is this is the good thing
to do
and you know being for individual
liberty is
i i'm going to say a bad thing because
they never frame it in those terms
because i don't think they really think
deep enough to
categorize it like that but well they
tell you you're selfish right if you're
for individualism it somehow sounds
selfish even though
i would i would argue that you should do
what is good for you and then you might
do also what's good for your family and
your extended community
and your your local community and all
that it's actually more simple than that
if you're arguing for group rights
you're arguing for rights that i don't
get to have
i can't imagine anything more selfish
than that i'm arguing for rights
everyone has
there's there's nothing more altruistic
than that as far as i can think of
you know it's just by definition i can't
that can't be the selfish position if
you're saying that you know
other people must have something i can't
have that's terrible it's absolutely
terrible
but some no i i don't i don't think
they're all bad people or anything
in fact
the majority of people are well-meaning
with without a doubt
you know they the these are the people
who they they log on they watch uh
certain online news venues and they
they think yeah okay yeah i agree of
course and uh right
and then they they just carry on with
their day and they they don't really
think about it
but there are definitely people who are
i don't know what you call them thought
leaders or something like that
uh who i mean there are definitely
certain individuals who
are doing what they're doing willfully
and they're pushing things
for specific agendas i mean there are
some people i mean
guardian author jessica valenti is is
just she's just
i mean she can't possibly think that
she's doing something altruistically and
if she does
that just speaks more to her mental
state than anything i mean
she actually in an article she actually
called just outright
for men to be paid less money than women
on the basis that their men as a
solution to closing the
wage gap in the article she got informed
by a lawyer that that would in fact be
illegal
because we have laws to say that you
can't pay people differently based on
their gender and all she was like well
bummer
i mean that they were her literal words
in the ass but it's like this person's a
lunatic
why why is she why does she have a job
at the guardian
i i mean i don't wrong that that's
actually the wrong question to ask
of course she has of course yeah yeah
yeah come on now uh yeah
yeah yeah but you see i i come from a
time when i
you know from the 90s when the guardian
was respectable paper and they didn't
push this sort to the
level they do now but you know what are
you gonna do um but yeah so that i i
i don't know necessarily but there are
definitely certain individuals who are
using
social justice advocacy and sort of the
extreme progressivism
as a cover for their own bad actions
because this is
this is what drives me crazy about it
the most is it's it's
so collectivist it's lost sight of the
individual
um look at their definition of racism
for example right so
if they say that racism isn't just
prejudice based on race which is
the definition everyone else uses you
know you're being prejudiced for this
person why because he's black
that's racism well if they then redefine
racism to mean
systemic oppression or prejudice based
on race or oppression whichever they
want to use
then an individual can never be accused
of being racist
because that individual is not the
organization i mean at best you could
say a representative of an organization
could be a racist
because he represents that organization
in an official capacity
but otherwise it just doesn't make sense
and then mathematics is terrible as well
i mean i
i'm terrible at maths as well but even i
know that if you have
if racism is power plus prejudice if
power is zero
it's just racism is prejudice right
from a mathematics point of view even i
know this you know if they if they had
any brains but between them
they've gone racism is power times
prejudice
so is that is that the issue though is
that the issue that it really in a way
it's sort of a brain power issue
because if you were to think a lot of
this stuff through if you were to think
what being a human is all about how
government should treat us how we should
treat our
neighbor and all of that none of it
really makes sense but it just kind of
sounds good which goes to you know
someone like ben shapiro always says
you know it's feelings over facts right
and that it all
kind of feels good and i know even in my
personal life now even though most
people know my
opinions on things when i when i'll meet
someone new and i'll talk about some
stuff and they're
they they feel a lot of this
when i start talking to them about it i
can see it's like in a personal affront
it doesn't become a political
conversation it's as if i'm
just attacking the person and that's a
really dangerous
place to be right yeah i mean this this
disregard for the individual
is it permeates the whole ideology and i
mean i read
an article today in fact where the there
was a woman talking about how
her ex-boyfriend had gone to a black
lives matter protest
after dedicating himself to being a
full-time social justice activist
and he had been uh i don't know man
handled by the cops
and they pushed him onto the floor and
she and i swear she wrote this
she said i wasn't worried for his safety
because the cops usually
something that killed more black people
more often than white people
and so she didn't have a fear for her
safety and so yeah but what if that is a
psychotic cop
and he's really pissed off with that guy
and he just pulls out his gun and shoots
him
and you'd be like well i mean they don't
usually do that it wouldn't change
anything the guy's still
dead right and they and they also shoot
plenty of white people too yeah well
they
per capita they shoot more white people
than black people
in total in aggregate they they keep
more open by people it's just
per capita it's disproportionately black
but um
i imagine there's probably something to
crime rates
crazy right um yeah all right so
this isn't to exonerate the police
though either because the u.s police
definitely have
um that in in certain departments are
definitely overbearing and authoritarian
there's no doubt about it i mean i
wouldn't want to get into a tussle with
the la cops
you know i i would be very respectful
and do exactly what they said when they
said it just because
but just to condemn police in general
and again
they it's it's collective blame and in
collective guilt and individual blame
they want to
you know they if something happens with
them like with black lives matter and
trevor noah
tommy uh lara the other day that
interview in infuriated me
i i was literally i mean i got to the
point where i was just what
i wanted to ask what does black lives
matter have to do
for you to stop supporting them trevor
you know they've murdered cops they
chant for cop dead cops all the time
they they riot they loot they burn they
beat people based on the you know
they're members who beat people on the
racial
uh racial status so i mean what has to
happen for him to go okay maybe this has
gone too far
but he just wants to you know whimsies
away going well that's just those people
but the grand narrative of black lives
matter isn't about that it's like well
it doesn't matter does it
well it's almost like you're kind of
caught at that point in
your collectivist bubble right you're
caught
between well we're doing something
that's collectivist
now we've got some bad apples here but
we don't want to be judged
as a collective but yeah
oh absolutely but the second a white man
does something
then it's all white men if you're a
white man you're oppressing women you're
replacing black people you're pressing
gays
you you are doing all of this stuff even
if you as an individual aren't doing it
because they are interested in the group
and not the individual and it's like
look
you want to have your cake and eat it
too you can either have i am responsible
and then
in turn black lives matter is
responsible for the crimes members of
black lives matter commit
or those individuals are responsible for
that and
i as an individual are responsible for i
do and
you know that i'm responsible for my
slaves okay
but um okay okay yeah yeah so it's it's
just
yeah it's just one of these things where
it's intellectual laziness
is really what i think it is and it just
becomes i mean there's a there's a
parody series on youtube called uh
regressives and the tagline is think
regressive
i can't remember it's easier or
something it's just easier and it really
is it's a lot easier to say
well this is white people's fault or
this is men's fault or this is you know
who i'm
saying that that doesn't answer anything
and that that's not actionable in any
way what do you
i mean what do you think we're going to
do stop well as jessica valenti wanted
just
demoting men's pay you know garnishing
men's pay
on the basis that they're men are you
it's the most illiberal thing i can
imagine and it's
kind of this kind of desire for forced
equality i find
baffling because in a free society
the last thing you'd expect to see is
sort of a perfect equality of anything
anywhere you'd expect to see lots of
individual people
all progressing through this society at
different rates because they've got
different interests different abilities
they come from different backgrounds
they want to do different things you
would never
expect to see like 50 men 50 women as
ceos
i mean why why would that happen i mean
these people have taken different
they've made different life choices to
arrive at the position that they're at
there is absolutely no rational reason
to expect it to be 50 50
and i'm still waiting for the
justification to make it 50 50.
why should that happen i mean why why
for diversity well that's not good
enough reason i'm afraid especially not
to
there was an australian uh ceo she was a
woman and she was i wasn't the ceo was
it the press we were reporting on
i can't remember exactly who it was but
it was an australian article i saw and
the
i'm sure was a ceo that was being
interviewed and the women literally said
well yes some men are going to have to
lose their jobs for diversity i know
there we go that's exactly that's
exactly my point these these people who
have worked their whole lives they've
done nothing wrong
and they've obviously earned everything
they've got are about to lose it
on the basis that they were born wrong
and i i can't countenance that i'm sorry
that's that's unacceptable
and it has to stop you know i've heard a
parallel on that which
is that you'll hear and i think oprah
said this once
we're talking talking about racists uh
that you know you just
we just need this older generation to
die and i remember thinking and you hear
this idea a lot you know that older
americans are more racist so we just
need them to die
and it's like that that's such a
dangerous endgame of why progressivism
will eventually eat itself
because you always need a new oppression
so one day even if you've lived your
whole life
as the most progressive person ever
there may be something that comes down
the pike 30 years from now
that you're like you know what i don't
think uh people should have sex with
robots
while in pools you know but the
progressives want and now they're gonna
want you dead too
not that i would problem with robot
water sex but
you know but that's the problem that it
just will eat itself
and it's like yeah that that's because
it's a purity test the whole damn thing
is a purity test
and i i've i feel sorry for those
sort of um the the whites progressive
college professors
who and i again this is another thing
that i've seen um
a woman a professor who's saying that
she can't have kids
because if she has kids they'll be white
and she'll be contributing to racism
because of course all white people are
racist because
you live in royal in the white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy
where all white people are uh privileged
and oppressed are by virtue of that
oppressing
non-white people and it's like okay and
then but
i love on the same hand that they're
like yeah and so you know i'm actually
really pro-immigration so why
why would you want to bring non-white
people into an oppressive
white society that's the worst thing you
can do for them that is the least
humanitarian thing
if you're a progressive it's incredible
there is no internal consistency in
their ideology
it's funny i was speaking i was speaking
at a high school a couple weeks ago
and they had you know a libertarian and
a liberal and an anarchist
and a socialist bubble and the socialist
white guy
kept going on and on about the evil male
patriarchy and white men and for white
men have pillaged this
and white men have destroyed that and i
literally turned to him on the thing and
i said you know you're white
so it's like the just the the lack of
self-awareness even
is just crazy